leadership is maybe the easiest and most
difficult thing to do it's easiest
because it's not determining you
good leadership is
bringing your people to lead and
bringing your people to bring their best
it's not about me it's about them and to
be able to do that you have to
give up of a lot of yours
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders let's talk
about inspiring technology that is
making the world better meet hari
goldpark the ceo of kando protecting
public health and the environment
through wastewater
ahri is an expert in wastewater and
environmental technologies with more
than 15 years of experience in the field
of wastewater management as the vice
president of dhvmed ari led
multi-disciplinary environmental
projects while managing international
teams environmental technologies at the
ministry of environment ari was
responsible for national and
international consulting project and
israel environmental policy as the
process manager and cto of jerusalem
wastewater treatment plan ari was in
charge of field operations ahri holds a
bsc in biology and environment from the
hebrew university jerusalem israel
ari goldfarb welcome to 20 minute
leaders ceo of condo how are you
i'm good michael and thank you for
having me here i i'm i love having you
here what you're working on is so cool
um you know we're seeing the surge of
companies that are dealing with with the
types of solutions that you're working
on and and literally looking at the
world and the infrastructure we have
here and how do we how do we you know
evolve our infrastructure at the end the
ripple effect of of doing that is
enormous on society and civilization not
to mention when we're talking about
wastewater both for you know
ecologically but also health-wise so a
lot of different implications and and
aria i'm excited to hear about your
personal journey
and and you know your leadership style
and and you know everything that's been
going on here so ari thank you for being
here
okay thank you mikhail oh where's your
start so
i'm very jealous in entrepreneurs that
have a someday they're waking up and
have a great idea for me it was a long
and exhausting journey to get where we
where we are and i can tell you it uh
starting when i was a a boy and i really
love the seas and the the going surfing
is is something i've done from a very
early age
and i've seen what happens to the seas
um and and i don't know have you been
lately in the mediterranean and i love
you love surfing so you you've done some
moving your hands and find the plastic
bag in your hands and you've seen
amongst many many other things that i
don't even want to mention here yes okay
so let's not mention it but for me it
was clear that i want to deal with that
and i i've learned the environmental and
biology and i went to treat wastewater
er and that's what i've done for almost
15 years uh treating wastewater design
wastewater dealing with technology of
getting our world better and our seas
and our ocean better
it but but what i find out that it's not
enough because the this whole pollution
is getting into our wastewater fighting
plant and from there it goes into our
beaches and into our seas and you've
seen how tel aviv looks after a rainy
day and
and i will tell you a secret it's not
just after a rainy day
and what i
have a vision and together with my
co-founder zoa
we decided that we want to
find a way to deal with it and our way
to deal with this is to understand where
it's coming from so if we can have a
system and and and understand everywhere
in the city when there is a pollution
with the there is a change in the
wastewater quality we can trace it back
understand where is the pollution coming
from and give an early warning to the
decision maker that will make our world
better and this was our vision
and we started in 2013
and we've done something that i'm not
sure that i would recommend anyone to do
that we made
our way through bootstrapping and step
by step we developed our system and we
went to clients and i think it
can happen only in israel we're going to
climb until we have this crazy idea that
we can identify all the pollution in
your system what do you say and they
believe in us and and they paid for our
system so our first investors were our
clients
take me back to that decision you know
and and paint me the picture because
you're in 2013 obviously now where you
know we're seeing specific tech funds
that are our venture capital funds that
are dedicated to the things that you're
working on um and so
what's happening in 2013 and and what is
this decision to bootstrap the company
going down a pretty rough process
yeah um
i think that we have a
very small vision that we want to change
the world so we said okay this is not
enough to make a technology we want to
make the world better we want to make
sure that all the pollution we can find
we can trace it we can change how the
our water looks like how our ocean looks
like our river looks like and actually
we started with investors and we met
some early investors and what we came
out is an idea that if we will have an
investor in the beginning and maybe we
met the right the wrong people now i
know we met their own people uh it will
be changed i mean we cannot achieve what
we really want
and we took it in the tough way in in
building it ourselves and fine finding
the funding the all this work by
ourselves well eight years later and you
have i believe more than 15 million
dollars of funding in your and then you
recently had you know the with the
series b and obviously making a strong
impact and so
i still i want to
you know ponder about this moment in
2013 as you're figuring out the market
and you're figuring out the problem and
you started by talking about
your jealousy of entrepreneurs that wake
up and have a good idea
how you know what type of entrepreneur
are you are you basically saying that
you were you know you had to do this
because it's something that was burning
in you or
what what made you go into this
entrepreneurial route
yeah i think the most important thing
for me and and also for the team that we
work with is about impacting
and
impacting the world the environment but
the end is impacting people i think
that's the most important thing for us
we we call sometimes people come to us
and say okay so what type of company are
you are you technology company are you
product company i think we are
definitely an impact company
we we learned that by the way
with one of our investors that is an
impact investor bridges and they taught
us to calculate this impact as well but
we've learned that our passion and what
we want to do is impacting and and
impact the environment and impacting
people that's the main thing and i i can
tell you a story what what type of
impact we do so for example um one of
our biggest client in texas
is reusing the wastewater and use it for
drinking this is what because they don't
have any water in in some places in
texas
yeah and and we find the way that to
make them available not only to reuse
the waste water their wastewater but
also to reuse wastewater they bring from
from mexico
and we met one of the
uh
one of our clients and she's managing
the project from the client side and we
sat with her and she said um you know we
have to present that to the management
i'm the only woman in the management i
never spoke in the management i never
present anything to the management so
you will do that
our customer success
iris she worked with her step by step
and teach her how to present it
and we went with her to the management
and he said okay i can do present and
you said no no you will present and she
presented to the management
uh and she showed how
texas is reusing the wastewater and
making this wastewater available for
people to drink and she done it and
after this meeting she told us it was
the significant the most significant
things i have done in my life wow so
yeah once you impact people like this
and you combine it with impacting the
environment i mean this gives you energy
to do to change the world so after that
you can do everything incredible and i
love how you know i i started this story
thinking you're talking about impact the
way that you're talking about impact on
a on a community or the solution for the
world but you're actually you know
talking about just the here you know a
monumental impact on a person but the
impact also stems from the impact that
she's having on a lot of other people
and i think that that's that's
phenomenal
talk to me about the grand vision here
you know eight years in the making what
is the vision of kendo
so we want very simple things to change
the world and to make it a better place
through data that we bring from
wastewater and impact the environment
and impact people public health and the
environment through data that we bring
from wastewater
and apparently wastewater tells us a
huge story because everything that
happens in the city ends up in the
wastewater
we can see a lot what happens in the
city so it's not just about finding
pollution and making our seas and ocean
better but it's also finding and
understanding people and health issues
through the wastewater so for example in
these pandemics we can identify
outbreaks through the wastewater and we
can protect public health through that
so we can tell people hey guys it's safe
to go outside nothing happens here it's
you can go back to work because we see
that through the wastewater so bringing
people the confidence being people the
ability to live normal life through
wastewater this is a huge thing that
we're doing right now so let's talk
about you know how data can actually
make it make a change here what is the
solution that kendo provides who is
looking at the solution and how does it
then translate into actionable insights
that they can then alter
the way that they're operating to make
the world better
so
if we talk about technologies our
solution is based on hardware and
software we have an iot data loggers
connected to sensors that can see
changes in the waste water quality
that communicate to the cloud in the
cloud we are looking at the behavior of
the wastewater actually wastewater is
something that doesn't have a normal
behavior because it always changes and
so we're looking at at the behavior of
the wastewater and through the behavior
of wastewater we can fist in things we
can see things like pollution so we can
identify pollution changes in the
wastewater quality we can identify
sources of pollution if there is an
industry discharging wastewater into the
collection system into the pipe
underground pipe we can see that
but we can see also the health of the
people of the population
and we have actually we have three type
of users one of our users is water
utilities and cities which they can see
the waste water quality and they have to
make sure that this waste water quality
is good enough because the wastewater is
being used again and again and again the
waste water that we are discharging into
the system goes back to us in israel for
example we use it for agriculture if you
eat a watermelon in israel you actually
eat a wastewater
so we use it again and again and again
and we are making sure through the water
utilities in the cities that those
wastewater are safe we use it for
government also so government can make
sure that they can protect the public
health and manage the public health
through wastewater now in kovit for
example a ministry of health have a
dashboard and through wastewater they
can see every outbreak and they can see
also when it's safe and there's no
outbreak and we also protect and help
the population so in our future in our
vision and this is something we are
working now with the uk government
people will have an application and like
they see the weather they can see the
public health they can see where there
is influenza where there is a covey
all these data coming from wastewater
systems
who is you know how does the incentive
triangle work here because i understand
why a government is incentivized to deal
with this i understand why climate tech
you know
advocates are
you know happy about this but why would
companies organizations
building managers why would they care
about implementing a solution like this
because there is a cult you know a a
customer shift in understanding that you
have to educate the market here
yeah so impacting people the environment
is only sustainable when it have
financial
input
only then it's sustainable uh
here when we're talking about pollution
pollution it's actually for cities and
we think for what utilities is money so
when
an industrial
plant is here discharging
a metal or heavy metal or organic or any
pollution into the system it's actually
making a damage to the underground pipe
it's making a damage to the treatment uh
and it's actually money and when we
identify pollution in our system we're
telling our clients here there is an
event here it's caused by this industry
and it will cause you 100 000 dollars if
you want to fix it so we can we connect
between the uh environmental impact and
the financial impact only then it's very
sustainable i i see and so you know the
work with these you know with the people
that are that are incentivized and i and
i love how you're describing that they
you know in order to make a real impact
it's not enough to to make people care
but they need to also see that it's also
beneficial for them economically because
at the end
this is the short term that they're
looking for in terms of the incentives
what what is the you know the potential
here you know how much can you actually
save or how much can you actually make
an impact economically through
data-driven decisions on on wastewater
when we're talking about potential
there's a
short-term potential when you're talking
about identified changes in wastewater
quality we're talking about
just to understand savings for one of
our cities that we work in the u.s gets
to two or three million dollars wow a
year uh that is only on savings but
imagine the city of around one million
people and we allow them to reuse all
the wastewater and bring
water to their population so how much
it's worth for a city to have more
available water when you live in a
desert and you don't have enough water
right so
i mean i mean this is this is a lot and
this is only the short term when you
look at the long term having the ability
to read the wastewater and understand
data from it so just imagine that now in
the coffee we we can we could see
the next outbreaks around two weeks
before it happened so when people when
people go to the restroom they're
carrying the virus like
10 days or around two weeks before they
have
symptoms so we can actually see the next
outbreaks before people knows about it
so getting the the government prepared
to the new outbreak this is one thing
and getting people released from this uh
situation tell them okay everything is
good now you can go back to work the
economy can go back to to a
business as usual this is a lot of money
for the market uh to bring the market
back so the opportunity of creating
values from where from data from
wastewater is is huge right now you're
you know running this company or
obviously with your partners and you
have a lot of team members that are
involved here and the story that you
told me before about the but the impact
and with the custom success manager and
the empowerment there i think it shines
light on a leadership style that you
have tell me a little bit about how you
see yourself as a leader
especially one that is motivated by the
inertia of potentially making the world
a better place
i think
leadership is maybe the easiest most
difficult thing to do it's easier
because it's not determining you
good leadership is
bringing your people to lead and
bringing your people to bring their best
it's not about me it's about them
and to be able to do that you have to
give up of a lot of yours
uh and only when you can give up a lot
of yours and it's something i'm still
training on and
then you can bring the best of your
people uh so being a leader is not about
not about us it's about the it's about
people you know i i the company success
is about
zoro making the company work and all
bringing the people and guy bringing the
product and kako bringing the
the the technology it's nothing related
to me but i have to bring them the
ability to do that and not to interrupt
so it's leadership it's just very very
simple not to interrupt and so what with
not interrupting it's also enabling them
to reach that potential and sometimes
perhaps you know
pushing or urging somebody to try
something that they may
fear or may not have experienced before
like in the story before what what have
you found is
successful doing that what you know
perhaps something that you do or
something that you've observed about
yourself and your leadership style that
that allows people to feel that they can
actually go and and try something that
they haven't tried before
so i think
we are in every startup is doing
something new unless i mean we want to
change things as it was before
and it's also related to the way we
manage and you also have to related the
way the internal process that we are
doing so
i think what we are trying to do is
doing things our way and not doing
things the way it should be done uh
and this is something i mean we call it
can do way by the way can do means uh in
japanese it means inspiring yes it means
wow
so and that is what we're trying to do
in everything we do er
and also in our management style also in
the day-to-day work uh we're trying to
do differently we're trying to do
something different
and and and there's a lot of things to
fix in our market in the technology
market in the startup market
i think a lot of things that are broken
and doesn't work very well
i would say for example
um
the share of women in the startup it's
something we have to fix
i think if you look at entrepreneurs and
anything the leadership in companies and
you open the linkedin and you see
another
three
mail
a startup that is raising money
and another one and another one and
another one and and i think this is
something we have to change and we're
trying to do something different here
and can do uh related to everything that
we do
i love it and i i don't know
can do i just love that uh that phrase
were you always passionate about climate
tech i know you're mentioning that you
know that you know the the motivation
behind what you started uh why you
started can do but you know if you're
looking at yourself as a kid you know 10
years old eight years old where did you
imagine that you're that one day you're
going to be leading a series b company
that is helping change the wastewater
management system
um
not true i'm all thinking about myself
as a nature researcher in africa
chasing lions or something similar to
that
but
i think the most important important
thing for me is to do something
significant to the world and to people
and and i i will say that everything we
do and everything i do is related to
people and
and everything my passion and and is
is people not just in my team
but all around so how can we impact
people how can make big people better
and and it's
not because of something very big it's
from something very small because i feel
when i when we touch people and touch
myself i'm getting better so i want to
get better and to improve myself
and i think the best way to improve your
surface is is by touching people when
when you come home after
after uh
you've seen people succeed you get a
better person you get a big better
father you're getting better their
partner so so i think the most
things for me the most passionate for me
is touching people phenomenal yeah ari
thank you very very much i really
appreciate your time and your energy
and this was uh inspiring and and really
interesting and uh definitely something
that i need to research much more about
now because i i i'm very you know these
types of solutions and beyond the
leadership perspective and the spirit i
think just the idea that you can create
economically viable solutions that at
the end have a such a strong ripple
effect we started by talking about
wastewater to data and then we finished
off talking about you know the way that
governments can now actually see when
there's outbreaks and we've seen what's
happened in the last year and a half
whether it's with covet or the next one
and the world is globalized and and
having control of the of this
information
is just a is just amazing so ari best of
luck with continuing to make an amazing
impact with can do thank you for taking
the time to sit here with me and stay
safe and stay healthy
thank you michelle thank you for having
me and i think we we are in the tech
companies have a huge power to do things
for
for the environment and for people and
we have to use it i completely agree
today
[Music]
you